all right let's talk about this
terrifying moment when a boulder hit
your car what happened
i was driving through a place called a
tuna canyons kevin a place where i've
never ever ever been in my life and not
only that but i never listened to my gps
and today
that day i listened to my gps my gps
took me that way wow i'll never do it
again i'll never listen to my gps again
stick to the highways flav
never listen never take another shortcut
again yeah yeah cause that yeah cause
that shortcut was getting ready to cut
me short where were you headed to flay i
was leaving vegas i was coming from
vegas on my way to bel air oh to my
studio
to do my podcast
and i didn't know that there were fallen
rock
you know what i'm saying but i've seen a
lot of rocks in the street and
everything so i'm like okay you got some
falling rocks around here
there was no signs of falling rocks or
anything like that you know
and as i'm driving kevin
all i see is
this
big giant object coming across my
windshield man and then it hit the
street and as soon as this boulder hit
hit the street
on the right side of my car
my
the rock raised my car
you know what i'm saying that's a lot of
damage for all and let's just clarify
everybody it wasn't just a rock that hit
your car it was a boulder that fell off
about
significant damage and
they're saying that a second later
and that would have hit you
check this out i was doing like maybe 36
37 miles per hour right when that
boulder came down
in front of my car if i was doing like
42 or 43 miles per hour
that would have pushed me up a few
seconds later that boulder would have
crushed the hood and the windshield of
my car
so
i just grazed i just brush up depth just
like that man i mean god is good god
wasn't ready for me kev i think he
wanted me to
be here sitting talking to you about it
um what happens the second that it hits
what do you do then what do you do the
only thing you can do is
keep going and get out the way and hope
that another one don't come down and hit
you and that's what i did because i
drove i drove away in fear because i
didn't know if there were more of those
big rocks coming
coming out of the mountain or not
you know so i drove down a few miles
and then i got out and i looked at my
car and when i got out kevin there was a
guy that was pulling over with me and
he was signaling to me to turn to roll
the window down i rolled my window down
he said
hey i seen that back there i said you
did and then as soon as i got out the
car he was like
oh my god flavor effin flav get out of
here man he said flame that bolt almost
killed you i said yeah
so you felt like clearly you're shaking
you get out of the car this guy
recognizes you but you're shaking and
you're still
traumatizing right now i'm still
traumatized right now bro i'm seeing
flashbacks
i'm seeing flashbacks like crazy right
now man you know when i went to
to go to sleep last night all i kept
seeing was that big rock falling in
front of my car man and almost
man listen god is good man do you hear
me he wasn't ready for me
okay he's ready for me kev how are you
dealing with this experience because i
know it left you shaken but how are you
what are you going to do for yourself to
deal with this experience the only thing
that i can do for myself is just try to
leave it in the past now just move
forward because
i'm grateful to be here you know so i
got no choice i mean it happened
yesterday so by me worrying about it
it's not going to help me today yeah
listen
it almost feels like a second lease on
life doesn't it like yeah
yes yes hey i feel like a cat that just
got another life
you are also celebrating one year of
sobriety yes congratulations thank you
thank you how are you feeling and how
are you feeling kevin man i feel so
great inside right now you know what i'm
saying and this is something that i
always wanted for myself i just could
never really grip it
but finally god gave me the strength to
be able to grip it and hold on to this
and this is something that my mom's
would want for me too i know she's
looking down on me and she's proud of me
because she always wanted me to live a
clean and sober life being that i'm not
smoking cigarettes my wind is a lot
longer you know what i'm saying um being
that i'm not drinking alcohol my
appetite is a lot healthier and heavier
now you know what i'm saying so i feel i
feel good and then also
a thing that really helps me stay in the
game is i have a lot of people rooting
rooting for me and cheering me on and
patting me on the back about my sobriety
and
and and i don't want to let them down
you know but yeah mainly i don't want to
let myself down people may not also know
that you have even more on your plate
you have an upcoming residency in las
vegas what can fans expect from that uh
the only thing i can say is they can
expect the best when they come to vegas
man i'm working on a residency now out
of the plaza hotel
you know what i'm saying and it's a it's
a it's a it's a talk variety show it's a
variety show that i'm coming with you
know and i'm gonna have all walks of
life coming through my stage you know
i'm saying even people like yourself
once i get to show up in the morning
kevin fraser i would love for you to
come on my stage and let me sit down and
interview you just like you're
interviewing me this will fight for if
we go so far back you know you call
right i'm there we go back come on yes
don't you have to
um and then there's also a documentary
you're working on yeah i'm working on a
documentary right now you know what i'm
saying i hooked up with my boy mark
wahlberg yeah you know what i'm saying
in his company to do my documentaries
what will fans learn in this documentary
they're going to learn the real life of
flavor flav and how flavor flav got to
be where he is right now today
all right can we talk about when you
reinvented yourself with the flavor of
love it is such an iconic tv show i got
a nice big mansion
but none of these things means nerd
hello
a woman to spend it with
could you first of all ever see yourself
doing another show like that again
honestly i never see myself doing a show
like that in the first
but
i'm glad that they did bring it to the
table you know what i'm saying and uh
you know um i i i had fun doing it i
ain't gonna lie are you still looking
for love are you still looking for love
man i find love every day i come out my
house kevin
but are you still looking for the right
one you're a studio and found love you
know that's people that love you but i'm
talking about
a love like as in your love life
you found a woman that makes you happy
i'm i'm i'm
i'm we're still looking we're still
looking okay we're still looking do you
do you keep you still looking i can't i
i i think i kind of got my finger on
something okay i can respect that i
think i kind of got my finger on
something
did you keep in touch with any of the
women from flavor of love
no i haven't kept in touch with none of
them but i've
been watching them from afar you know
what i'm saying
and i'm proud of a of a few of them that
made i'm gonna throw a couple names out
here i want to i just want to hear what
you think okay when i say their name you
just give me something all right
um let's start with pumpkin your pumpkin
where you at
pumpkin yeah or she was a nut man i i i
haven't i haven't seen pumpkin in a long
time but i've seen a picture of her and
i've seen a change hoops i love
basketball that's my girl nikki
alexander yeah let me tell you something
out of all of the girls that came
through my show
she was the finest one
wow okay i hear you on that
how about new york
new york was the nuttiest one hey you
can't help but love new york man new
york is really who she is you know what
i'm saying and not only that but she's
not a bad girl she's a good girl i love
new york
yeah no i love her man yeah yeah i love
her man she's mad cool do you keep in
touch with bridget nielsen i haven't
spoken with bridget in a long
time man i miss bridget i miss keita
yeah yeah i miss her man that was my
that was my pal that's my that was my
pal she's still my pal yeah she's one of
the best people man you'll ever really
want to know and me
let's be honest you're ready to do
another flavor of love aren't you
thinking about it kevin it's coming
isn't it thinking about it i'm thinking
about it it's it's up in the air you
know what i'm saying and and we would
and if we do we were talking about
letting chris jenner produce it
everything that lady touches turns
yeah she's a genius let me tell you
something i am so glad that we can have
this conversation today because you are
here and you escaped i mean it was close
but you escaped yes i really did a tough
situation g-i-g
everybody has a gig a g-i-g
but my new gig is
god is good
i'm here to talk to you about kevin mann
and i want to be here for years and
years and years to come and talk
more
more with you man
[Music]
you